[Musique]
bonsoir petit ami oh
oh ce lendemain de feurs tels silos ce
pas trop et oui nounours mais je pense
que nicolas et pimprenelle ont quand
même envie de te voir et moi aussi j'ai
envie de voir et j'y vais de ce pas mon
le seul
pape à propos
[Musique]
soit
c'est bien vu ce soir
cornichons et partie oui dice et parents
sont venus chercher mais l'a promis
qu'il reviendra pas au mieux
[Musique]
gridsure
9e ce qu'il dessine bien mais je
reconnais l'écriture d'emilia
mosher ce
qu'est ce qu'est l'église à cheikh sarr
les cris joyeux nos
caisses et gentil
joaillier maël
nouvelle avec les rues une lettre tu
veux le nom selon ti du mois tu prends
un crayon bleu à tous et moi l'eau qui
nous ont fait les dessins mais usher
non chers amis merci pour votre belle le
bonhomme de neige est très réussi le
bonhomme de
jeu vous dessine à naviaux et moi le
portrait de notre ami tony chan le
portrait
vous le permet nous faire on a de
nouveau je vois qu on s'amusera conso
but
à bientôt gros baiser nicolas traînait
là bon joueur
bon baisers nos meilleures salutations
ronchères et dévouée a mis pape rhône
elle et nicolas c'est plus élégant
tu as raison ça fait sérieux très bien
je leur envoie cette lettre par exprès
ceux qui vont être heureux d'avoir de
vos nouvelles
n'oubliez pas gelé juin bonne nuit les
enfants allaient vue de vous coucher
[Musique]
bonne nuit cher gros nounours ou federer
n'est pas bonne elle dort bien
[Musique]
où
pas trop vous vous arrêterez au dessus
du bureau de poste le plus proche j'ai
une lettre urgente a expédié d'accor
north en route la nuit les enfants faute
de boer
[Musique]